تنفس العالم السعداء فالصاروخ الذي اصاب
قريه بولنديه على الحدود مع اوكرانيا لم
يكن هجوما روسيا بل صاروخا اطلقه الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني تلك حقيقه بات يتقاسمها
الان حلف الناتو وسائر الدول الغربيه بما
فيها بولندا التي شهدت الحادث وحده الرئيس
الاوكراني
لا تقنعه تلك الخلاصات ويصر على ان الهجوم
روسي
قدمت لي من القياده الجويه ومن غير زولوج
لنفسه عن الحادثه ليس لدي ادنى شك بان
الضربه الصاروخيه لم تكون اوكرانيه
ولان الحادثه غير المسبوق كان اشبه ببروفا
لخطر انزلاق الحرب خارج مسارها بمجرد ان
يظل صاروخ طريقه ولو خطا فقد بلغ لانشغال
الغربي ان تداعى النيت الى اجتماع ازمه
طارئ وعاجل على مستوى سفراء في بروكسل كما
عرضت المانيا على وارسو دعم مراقبه
اجوائها بدوريات تؤمنها
مقاتلاتر في الولايات المتحده اعتبر البيت
الابيض الا تعارض بين حقيقه ان الصاروخ
الذي سقط في بولندا اوكراني وحقيقه ان
روسيا هي المسؤوله في النهايه عن هذا
الحادث الماساوي فهي التي اطلقت وابل من
الصواريخ على اوكرانيا امال انتاج فتكفل
بتقدير الموقف العسكري على الجبهات رئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه الجنرال مارتنلي
اعتبر ان روسيا تخسر على كل الجبهات
لكنهما مع ذلك لا يتوقع احتماله ان تنجح
اوكرانيا في دفع القوات الروسيه للانسحاب
من كامل اراضيها وعليه فالارجح ان يحتاج
الامر الى تسويه سياسيه على حد قوله